i've seen him go through a lot but i
always know his heart
kim kardashian and kanye west went
through a reported rough patch earlier
this year
and now a source tells e.t there's still
trouble in paradise
but they are doing their best i mean we
have different views sometimes we have
different
things but that's my husband quote kim
is exhausted from continually trying
but keeps their vows in mind when making
any pertinent decisions
and kanye is working on his
psychological health and
mental state the family and kanye are
still in contact
and everyone wants the best for kanye
kim their kids
and the rest of the family the source
adds that kim feels like kanye needs to
work on himself before he can work on
the well-being of anyone else
as for the skims designer well our
source says she's considering what's
best for the kids
herself kanye and the rest of the family
essentially in that order at the end of
the day life is about being happy
and the source says kim's famous fam
will support her
in any decision she makes i feel like we
are so blessed to have the best support
system and the best family
to really just support each other no
matter what we're going through
of course all this comes after a very
public debacle back in july during a
political rally in
south carolina when kanye revealed he
and kim talked about having an abortion
when she was pregnant with their first
child
north so even if my wife were to divorce
me
after this speech she brought north into
the world
even when i didn't want to she stood up
and she protected that child
kanye also went on a subsequent twitter
rant of since deleted comments about his
wife and her family
all that led to kim making a lengthy
public statement about her husband's
mental health
and kanye was quick to issue a public
apology to her
he's just the most genuine person
and you know he might say things that
might get misinterpreted and people
don't see the context behind
it but in october a source told et that
the two were in a great place
and spending a lot of quality time
together with their kids and family
quote the couple knows they have to work
on things but they're putting in the
effort
[Applause]
[Music]
the couple seemed in great spirits when
kanye joined his wife and
several close relatives and friends for
her milestone 40th birthday celebration
on a private island
happy birthday kimberly
look at you you're 40 and all grown up
but it was the gift he gave her a
hologram of her late father robert
kardashian
that clearly left kim feeling moved in
the sweetest way
thank you for that
seriously thank you